no I'm not kidnapped I'm just in my
house right now and I love all the
people who to worry about me but it was
time for me to take some time to be by
myself that's fitness guru Richard
Simmons opening up exclusively to et's
executive producer Brad Bessie on Sunday
the 67 year old addressed recent
speculation over his whereabouts and
explained why he hasn't been seen in
public for more than two years for the
last 40 years of traveling teaching
classes and I had a knee injury so I had
a knee replacement which was very
difficult for me and now my other knee
is hurting and I don't want to have
another replacement so I've just really
been taking it easy staying at home
working out of my gym and doing the
things that I haven't done in the very
long time so I wanted to take some time
out right now and take care of me the
exercise enthusiasts insisted he's fine
and even said he plans to eventually
return to the spotlight oh I'll be back
I just like I said you know I just
didn't want to do anything right now and
no one should be worried about me the
people that surround me or wonderful
people who take good care of me despite
allegations that he's become reclusive
due to a weight gain Simmons fired back
revealing nothing could be further from
the truth why still weigh 150 I work out
every day I have a gym here at the house
and I'm very healthy the sweatin to the
oldies creator was last seen publicly at
a holiday event in December 2013 and
reportedly suffered his knee injury in
November 2014 4 more with Richard
Simmons tune in to ET on Monday March 14